oh this is a train wreck waiting that  she's gonna leave him she's gonna leave  him I thought it's crazy because she  used to be known as like the good girl  in Hollywood like you remember when she  was younger she was like oh I don't take  off my clothes everyone thought this is  how this is why I say women are a roll  of the dice women are a roll the dice  she was talking in her early 20s she  doesn't like to show her body off like  that sis then starts posing naked at  like 30. like guys are like oh you bet  her I'm like this man has known this  girl since high school he's known her  since high school he done vetted her  sometimes women we just go crazy I yeah  um this is a nightmare  um I think she'll divorce him in the  next five years